grazie
l'uomo usa da sempre le piante per
curare e per prevenire le malattie da
qui il termine piante officinali piante
destinate alle officine farmaceutiche
per la produzione di farmaci
quindi ha portato qualche esempio questa
è una pianta di calendula e viene
utilizzata per cicatrizzare le ferite e
per emolliente per la pelle
questa è una pianta di elicriso anche
questa con proprietà cicatrizzanti è
stata utilizzata molto anche come
antisettico e questo è invece una pianta
sicuramente più nota per il suo uso in
cucina ma che anche delle proprietà come
tonico stimolante del sistema digestivo
e del sistema nervoso per oggi non vi
voglio parlare di questo
vi voglio parlare del futuro e di quello
che viene dopo di questo tipo di
applicazione vi voglio parlare in
particolar modo di questa pianta
molti di voi magari non la riconoscono
in questa forma ma la riconoscono in
questa forma
questo è un sigaro e questa è una pianta
di tabacco e vi voglio raccontare di
come in questa pianta di vogliamo usare
questa pianta di tabacco per produrre un
vaccino per il diabete di tipo 1 il
diabete di tipo 1 è una malattia di tipo
autoimmune c'è una malattia in cui il
sistema immunitario scatena una risposta
verso le cellule dell'organismo
nel caso del diabete quello che succede
è che si distruggono le cellule che nel
pancreas producono l'insulina una volta
di diabete si moriva ora non più grazie
alla disponibilità appunto di questo
ormone però i malati di diabete devono
ricorrere a somministrazione di insulina
tutti i giorni
inoltre i malati di diabete hanno delle
forti complicanze croniche
cioè si rivelano danni al sistema
nervoso ai reni e al sistema vascolare e
questi problemi quindi le complicanze
croniche associate alle necessità di
somministrare l'insulina tutti i giorni
fanno sì che questa malattia abbia un
forte impatto sociale
questi sono un po di numeri come vedete
ogni
hanno 80 mila bambini sviluppano questa
malattia e parlo di bambini perché il
picco dell'insorgenza è tra gli 11 ei 12
anni
nell'immagine del mondo vedete come è
diffusa la malattia in totale ci sono
più di un milione di persone malate di
diabete autoimmune e come vedete la
diffusione più alta al nord e tende a
decrescere al sud con l'eccezione
dell'australia i dati inoltre indicano
che l'incidenza di questa malattia sia
raddoppiando ogni vent'anni è uno dei
fattori che rende difficile lo studio e
la prevenzione di questa malattia è il
fatto che solo il 5 per cento dei
pazienti malati hanno i genitori con la
malattia per eliminarla completamente
per cercare di evitare che ci sia questa
distruzione del sistema immunitario che
poi si scateni tutto questo tipo di
risposta sarebbe necessario trovare un
sistema di prevenzione un sistema che
sia in grado di eradicare la malattia in
tutta la popolazione perché adesso come
dicevo non è possibile prevenirla per
fare questo bisognerebbe mettere in atto
una strategia come quella dei vaccini
quella che si usa per i vaccini per
vaccinare le persone per evitare che si
contraggano infezioni o altre malattie
quindi un vaccino per una malattia
autoimmune e per realizzare questo
bisognerebbe semplicemente prendere una
dei primi target del sistema immunitario
che si trova dentro il pancreas
una piccola molecola è una proteina
prendere questa e darla alle persone
prima che si ammalino di diabete dare
questa proteina da mangiare per periodi
abbastanza lunghi si parla di circa un
mese
in questo modo si innescherebbe un
sistema che è quello che si usa per
svezzare i bambini che gli si danno
quantità crescenti di un certo alimento
per evitare che questi poi sviluppino
risposte immunitarie cioè diventa il
sistema immunitario diventa tollerante e
quindi evita poi tutta la cascata che
porta alla malattia
qual è il problema associato a questo
approccio che potrebbe risolverla
risolvere appunto
togliere la malattia della popolazione
il problema è che questa molecola di cui
vi parlavo prima questa piccola proteina
che si trova nel pancreas ha dei costi
di produzione che sono molto alti
è un biofarmaco c'è un farmaco che
deriva appunto da una fonte biologica in
questo caso il nostro pancreas e come si
producono normalmente biofarmaci bene
una volta quello che si faceva era
prendere le sorgenti tradizionali
quindi nel caso di questa proteina
avremmo dovuto prendere il pancreas di
un cadavere o il pancreas di animali
perché hanno una proteina molto simile
alla nostra estrarre la proteina per poi
darla appunto da mangiare a la
prevenzione del diabete
capite che questo approccio presenta
tantissimi limiti innanzitutto solo per
motivazioni etiche perché anno a un
larese sarebbe molto bassa quindi
bisognerebbe sacrificare un grandissimo
numero di animali ma poi anche per
questioni di sicurezza perché il
materiale di partenza potrebbe essere
infettato presentare ai virus batteri
che possono poi essere trasmessi alle
persone che si vaccinano quindi per
superare questo problema la produzione
dei biofarmaci adesso avviene attraverso
l'ingegneria genetica cioè che cosa si
fa si prende l'informazione il dna che
serve per produrre questa molecola e lo
si trasferisce a delle cellule semplici
a dei batteri o dei lieviti che vedete
nell'immagine in questo modo si
riprogrammano queste cellule per far sì
che diventino delle vere e proprie
fabbriche per la produzione di questa
molecola sotto vedete è indicata un
impianto in cui vengono coltivate e
vengono di solito punto fermentate
queste cellule per produrle ad alto
titolo e con questo sistema per esempio
viene prodotta l'insulina che compriamo
in farmacia insulina deriva proprio da
batteri geneticamente modificati ora
però nel caso della molecola di cui vi
parlavo prima quella da usare per la
prevenzione del diabete come vaccino per
il diabete
il problema è che comunque con questo
sistema non si riusciva a produrre in
modo adeguato che si doveva ricorrere a
delle cellule
complesse che richiedevano dei costi
degli investimenti molto alti nel
appunto per impianti di produzione e
comunque la resa era ancora molto bassa
e quindi quale può essere la soluzione
la soluzione può appunto venire dalle
piante quando per la prima volta lessi
queste parole ero ancora all'università
stavo studiando appunto in biotecnologie
e ho letto queste parole ho capito che
tutti i miei studi avevano un senso cioè
mi sono innamorata di questo progetto
perché ho capito che c'era un modo di
usare le piante geneticamente modificate
per produrre qualcosa di utile
qualcosa che avesse un impatto forte
sulla società perché quando parliamo di
biofarmaci parliamo di tutto parliamo di
vaccini per il tetano per la malaria per
l'aids
parliamo di pd qualsiasi di anticorpi
vengono usati per bloccare delle
patologie
parliamo veramente di medicinali
sofisticati e che normalmente si
producono con costi altissimi e le
piante potevano abbattere tutto questo
potevano abbattere i costi potevano
abbattere le barriere poteva poteva
potevamo produrre queste queste proteine
questi biofarmaci in modo sostenibile e
quando nel 1999 per la prima volta mario
pezzotti mi ha proposto questo lavoro mi
ha proposto di applicare questa
tecnologia air il diabete autoimmune
ho capito che tutto aveva un senso e e
quindi ho iniziato con il progetto
la cosa che più mi entusiasmava anche
tra il fatto che ne vedevo un inizio che
era il problema alla produzione di
questa molecola è la fine la soluzione
effettivamente alla fine non era così
vicina perché come vi dicevo iniziato
nel 1999 e ci sto ancora lavorando e
penso che questa immagine esemplifichi
bene il mio percorso
io avevo questa carota davanti questo
obiettivo da raggiungere che era chiaro
era definito era lì tra vicinissimo e
ogni passo che facevo per raggiungerlo
l'obiettivo si allontanava sempre un po
di più perché
nascevano nuovi problemi si
prospettavano anche nuove soluzioni
c'erano nuovi modi di vedere la cosa
nuove ottimizzazioni richieste così
continuava andare avanti di strada ne ha
fatta tanta perché appunto nella ricerca
nell'inseguimento della carota
ho camminato tanto è quello che ho
imparato è che una caratteristica
fondamentale per fare questo tipo di
lavoro per la ricerca scientifica è
proprio la perseveranza che è una
caratteristica che appunto mi accomuna
all'asino bene tornando al tabacco e
alla come sistema di produzione per
questo vaccino
uno dei motivi per cui assenza questa è
stata scelta questa pianta è il fatto
che è un sistema di produzione molto
economico cioè si produce con
investimenti molto bassi ora l'idea
chiaramente non era di vaccinare i
bambini per il diabete dandogli da
fumare questo ma l'idea era quella di
estrarre la proteina tirarla fuori da
queste foglie e qui il progetto costava
un po di più però era fattibile in
questa pianta altri scienziati in tutto
il mondo hanno prodotto vaccini per la
malaria come vi dicevo per l'aids
rispettano per il papilloma virus per
tantissime malattia e quindi un sistema
che funziona è fattibile un'altra
caratteristica delle piante appunto
geneticamente modificate per la
produzione di questi biofarmaci e il
fatto che sono estremamente veloci è
possibile ottenere milioni di dosi di
vaccino in 20 30 giorni ed è per questo
motivo che il ministero della difesa
degli stati uniti ha finanziato con 8
milioni di dollari dei siti per la
produzione di questi sistemi vegetali e
quando l'anno scorso in liberia sono
stati trattati due medici per
l'infezione di ebola con un mix di
anticorpi in quel caso quegli anticorpi
derivano proprio da questa pianta ed
erano stati prodotti in questi siti
un altro vantaggio delle piante è la
loro versatilità noi fino adesso abbiamo
parlato del tabacco però è possibile
sempre attraverso l'ingegneria genetica
andare a trasformare delle piante che
sono commestibili per l'uomo come per
esempio il riso il frumento l'orzo ma
anche piante da frutto come presento la
banana il kiwi o altre specie vegetali
in questo modo l'idea è che in futuro si
possa veramente arrivare a fare delle
vaccinazioni estese accessibili a tutti
semplicemente con una banana andando a
mangiare una banana
nel caso del diabete abbiamo seguito
questa strada e quello che abbiamo fatto
è stato modificare questa pianta per la
produzione del vaccino
questa è una pianta di rapa rossa quindi
è commestibile viene mangiata
normalmente e anche questa è stata
modificata per la produzione di questa
proteina in questo modo l'idea è come vi
dicevo prima di mangiare direttamente
delle capsule preparate a partire da
queste foglie senza andare a estrarre
come facevamo per il tabacco
bene adesso voglio darvi un'idea della
sostenibilità di questo approccio farvi
capire veramente perché sono più
economiche le piante tra tanto proprio
di questo caso specifico quindi del
vaccino per il diabete autoimmune una
dose per avere la dose per un vaccino
per vaccinare una sola persona
servirebbero 5 kg di pancreas di maiale
con costi che non sono nemmeno sa
calcolare perché è difficile trovare il
pezzo del panthers del maiale sul
mercato
l'altro sistema si basa su cellule in
coltura quindi come vi dicevo prima
queste cellule geneticamente modificate
per produrre questo vaccino hanno dei
costi che sono elevati infatti vedete
che il costo totale per una singola
vaccinazione sarebbe pari a 2.000 euro
e questo perché le procedure in questo
caso per la produzione di questa
molecola sarebbero molto sofisticate
quando passiamo alle piante vedete come
i costi si abbattono completamente nel
caso del tabacco
ci basterebbe una foglia così per fare
la dose per il vaccino per una persona
con costi totali appunto come potete
vedere stimati intorno ai 14 euro
realizzare una vaccinazione completa con
la rapa questo si abbatte ancora di più
proprio perché come vi dicevo prima non
devo purificare la proteina il costo di
14 euro
ovviamente non è il costo del tabacco
altrimenti non fumerebbe più nessuno
vero ma il costo proprio delle strategie
per purificare la proteina nel caso
della rapa come vi dicevo questo non ci
servirebbe quindi sono i costi
semplicemente associati alla
coltivazione di questa pianta perché una
volta che la modifica genetica è stata
fatta questa poi si può perpetuare
all'infinito senza nessun costo
aggiuntivo
l'ultimo approccio di cui vi voglio
parlare è quello che si basa sui virus
cioè non possiamo usare non solo le
piante per produrre bio farmaci ma
addirittura i loro virus è un esempio di
questa applicazione che vi voglio dare
l'abbiamo usata anche per il diabete
autoimmune ma un'applicazione che
ritengo essere bellissima riguarda l'uso
di questi virus per trattare il i tumori
e cosa si fa si prendono i virus
vegetali che non fanno male all'uomo
perché siamo abituati a mangiarli tutti
i giorni attraverso la frutta e la
verdura e si fonde sulla loro superficie
un radar è in grado di riconoscere in
modo specifico le cellule tumorali e al
loro interno si caricano delle sostanze
tossiche
in questo modo cosa succede questi virus
sono dei veri e propri cavalli di [ __ ]
entrano nel nostro organismo riconoscono
la cellula tumorale
entrano e liberano il cargo è tossico
in questo modo vanno a uccidere in modo
selettivo quelle celle
questo è solo uno dei tanti esempi della
ricerca biotecnologica che si fa anche
qui all'università di verona e vorrei
concludere con questa immagine perché
questa immagine per me evoca quello che
sono le biotecnologie
in particolare questo arco di arcobaleno
rappresenta la ricerca scientifica e nel
caso delle geotecnologie la ricerca
scientifica si complimenta con quello
che è l'approccio l'approccio
tecnologico
in questo modo si crea un arcobaleno
circolare che è un fenomeno ottico che
si può osservare solo da certe
angolature e che dà l'idea di come
l'approccio biotecnologico sia appunto
un approccio circolare con un inizio e
una fine
grazie